[Música]
y
el presidente de chile gabriel boric a
poco más de dos meses de haber llegado
al palacio de la moneda realizó por
primera vez la cuenta pública
correspondiente al año 2022 este evento
tradicional de la política chilena que
tiene lugar en la sede del congreso en
la ciudad de valparaíso
es un espacio para que el presidente
lleve a cabo un discurso para dar a
conocer cómo está el estado
administrativo y político del país en
esta ocasión el presidente boris
estructuró su discurso en cinco ejes
temáticos y se tomó poco más de dos
horas y cinco minutos para poderlos
explicar estos fueron los ejes de temas
que abordó el mandatario chileno el
primer punto fueron los derechos
sociales el segundo fue mejor democracia
el tercero justicia y seguridad el
cuarto crecimiento inclusivo y el quinto
se refirió a los temas relacionados con
el medio ambiente
por supuesto dentro de esos ejes de
temas pues hubo múltiples temas
abordados que reflejan las acciones
hechas por el gobierno en ese poco
tiempo que ha estado en el palacio de la
moneda y también habló sobre lo que
venderá para lo que continúa en su
gobierno que se extiende hasta el 2026
pero se destacar algunos temas como la
reforma a las pensiones también una
posible reforma tributaria hablo de
seguridad de un fondo solidario de salud
hablo por supuesto de educación y de
medioambiente por eso hoy en el debate
de france 24 vamos a analizar la primera
cuenta pública del presidente de chile
gabriel boric para analizar este tema
saludamos a jose miguel cabezas él es
profesor asistente del centro de
investigación en sociedad y salud de la
universidad mayor él se encuentra en la
ciudad de santiago en chile y también
allí en la capital chilena se conecta
tomás duval él es académico de la
universidad autónoma de chile ustedes
nuestros televidentes también hacen
parte de esta conversación pueden dejar
todos los comentarios y preguntas a
través de las redes sociales ya lo saben
estamos en facebook en instagram en
twitter y también pueden ver nuestra
señal en streaming a través de youtube
no se encuentran como a france 24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal y
nuestra etiqueta es numeral el debate
efe 24 esperamos todos sus comentarios y
sus preguntas relacionadas con este tema
comienzo entonces con josé miguel
comienzo por darle la bienvenida del
programa gracias por acompañarnos hoy
'josé miguel' desde la ciudad de
santiago y me gusta llamar a esta
primera pregunta el punto de partida
para el análisis y para la discusión
sobre este tema como punto de partida
entonces le preguntó 'josé miguel' cuál
es su balance de esta cuenta pública sus
impresiones y ya luego iremos entrando
en los diferentes temas que abordó el
presidente muy bueno mucho santiago al
día que nos escuchan hoy día escuchamos
por primera vez la cuenta pública del
presidente nada más 80 días habiendo
asumido su gobierno en el cual traza las
grandes líneas o los caminos por los
cuales caminaremos los próximos cuatro
años en términos generales yo pienso que
el discurso de día de hoy no invita o
convoca al país plantea una hoja de ruta
pero también a la abierta medidas
concretas y anuncios que se le dicen
materializarse en el corto plazo y que
apuntan fundamentalmente
en mi opinión ha convocado de convencer
particularmente a las mujeres a los
adultos mayores y también probablemente
a la clase media media baja no a los
sectores de ingresos medios y que son
ingresos medios bajos promoviendo
políticas inmediatas en el corto plazo
que también propuestas de reformas
legislativas en el mediano y largo plazo
le doy también la bienvenida entonces a
tomarás duval en la ciudad también de
santiago como punto de partida su
balance de esta cuenta pública
impresiones iniciales sobre lo que le
dejó este discurso de poco más de dos
horas desde la ciudad de valparaíso
bienvenido
buenas noches muchas gracias por la
invitación buenas
santiago
lloran una impresión es que el
presidente boliche en este primer
mensaje ha establecido una hoja de ruta
de que cuáles son las prioridades de su
gobierno en estos cuatro años y desde
ese punto de vista él ha colocado el eje
de las transformaciones en base a un
diagnóstico
a un diagnóstico que la sociedad estaría
anhelando y por lo tanto él plantea un
eje de transformaciones que abarcan
estos cinco ejes que tú bien ha señalado
al comienzo y que se traducen en 102
medidas concretas que el gobierno
compromete en su acción política quizás
lo más importante de esta primera cuenta
pública del presidente sea a quien ahora
ya delinea claramente los ejes y las
políticas que serán centrales en su
gobierno
ejes centrales de su gobierno también ya
ha tenido un poco más de dos meses para
hacer una especie de diagnóstico para
ver cómo está el estado cómo está el
país para empezar a mover ya sus planes
de gobierno en las diferentes áreas
áreas en jose miguel tomás y les parece
bien yo creo que para el programa para
analizar los diferentes puntos guillermo
nos precisamente por esos cinco ejes que
determinó el presidente en su en su
cuenta pública para irnos guiando de esa
misma manera entonces el comienzo con
tomás para hacer la ronda a la inversa y
el primer punto son los derechos
sociales allí el presidente habló de ese
sistema de pensiones que necesita
urgentemente una intervención que
necesita una reforma una actualización
en esto como como puede llegarse a dar
es viable el tema de las pensiones en
chile siempre ha sido un tema un poco de
agarrar con pinzas para los chilenos
esto será bien recibido por los
ciudadanos y también pues por los
políticos las diferentes clases
políticas como lo ve usted tomás
yo creo que la reforma del sistema de
pensiones es una demanda que lleva ya
más de 10 años en nuestro país y por lo
tanto lo que hace el presidente gabe de
boliches recoger esa demanda y darles
seguridades respecto a la reforma
en primer lugar él dice no vamos aquí a
refundar a establecer todo de nuevo
los fondos de los que tienen hoy día
ahorrado muchos ciudadanos en una
capitalización individual no serán
tocados y por lo tanto en el parte desde
ese desde ese piso y de ahí asegurando
incluso una pensión básica de alrededor
de 250 mil pesos
me parece que es el proyecto más central
quizás uno uno de los más centrales
mejor dicho y que muy anhelado por la
ciudadanía y ha estado en el centro del
debate de distintos gobiernos sin que
todavía veamos
efectivamente en qué consiste este nuevo
sistema de pensiones y 'josé miguel' su
opinión sobre este tema vemos que hay
reclamos por parte de la ciudadanía como
lo menciona tomás desde hace más de diez
años pidiendo una transformación de este
sistema pero que hay del empresariado
que hay también de la clase política el
presidente hablaba de un proceso de
diálogo social y amplio para poder
avanzar en este en esta transformación
pero si hay apertura a un diálogo en
chile para buscar una transformación del
sistema de pensiones
efectivamente en su cuenta público del
día el presidente la señal es clara de
que está dispuesto a sentarse a dialogar
al sentarse a encontrar puntos medios
con los distintos actores situación
bastante distinta a la que observamos en
noviembre-diciembre por ejemplo en plena
campaña presidencial donde incluso se
hablaba extraoficialmente o se utilizaba
como crítica la expropiación de la capa
de la capitalización individual cosa que
hoy día queda completamente echada por
tierra y por lo tanto da una respuesta
yo creo que bastante astuta y eficiente
al mercado no al mercado financiero y
también a los inversionistas extranjeros
empieza a dar señales de tranquilidad de
certeza jurídica que se le había
criticado mucho en estos últimos meses
esta próxima semana en particular que
todas estas propuestas de reformas
generaban y por tanto el anuncio hoy día
echa por tierra estas grandes
ideas de destruir y construir sino que
simplemente seguir trabajando lo que ya
se ha hecho pero también dar certeza
jurídica
hacia los aceros inversionistas tanto en
el interior perdón en el país cambien
con el extranjero que era algo que se
estaba demandando mucho también quisiera
destacar que en los últimos días se
logró también
publicar con la venia con el acuerdo del
legislativo el aumento del sueldo mínimo
mínimo que en términos generales era el
resguardo los 500 dólares hoy día con un
aumento real nunca antes visto en
términos porcentuales perdón nunca antes
visto en los últimos 10 o 20 años por lo
tanto es efectivamente los gobiernos
está dando señales concretas de una
construcción de un modelo de protección
social que paradójicamente fuera el
logan de muchos gobiernos anteriores
pero que hoy día finalmente después de
34 gobiernos distintos después de casi
15 20 años efectivamente se empieza a
materializar y también en esa misma
línea el mensaje de hoy el presidente da
cuenta nombra a presidentes ya la
presidenta previo a él incluso de la
oposición diciendo que vamos a tomar el
bastón vamos a recorrer ese camino y en
base a lo malo a lo ya construido
vamos a construir aún más
si no es dar pasos hacia atrás para
intentar ir hacia adelante sino a partir
del punto donde finalizó otro gobierno
el tomate como punto de partida en la
salud interesante lo que propone el
presidente de cara a lo que le resta de
gobierno presentar un proyecto de ley
que creará un fondo universal de salud
también buscar un poco es privatizar
como lo ve uno desde afuera que
prácticamente la vida de los chilenos
está completamente privatizada y si hay
algo privatizado en la educación y la
salud es costosa no es fácil de acceder
para todas las regiones y para todos los
chilenos el tema de la salud 'josé
miguel' punto clave
también habrá consenso fácil dentro de
los diferentes grupos políticos o es un
proyecto también mucho más difícil de
lograr que se cambien las pensiones
mi análisis político que mucho pero que
mucho más difícil la reforma de
pensiones respecto al sistema de salud
porque porque el sistema de salud
también tiene un beneficio o un premio
muy corto inmediato en el corto plazo
para todos los actores políticos por
tanto todos tienen bastante interés en
ser parte de este triunfo no de este
logro
lo segundo es que efectivamente hemos
tenido errores heredad perdón errores
heredados de distintos gobierno de
distintos cortes políticos y el
presidente da cuenta de eso en
particular con las cirugías con las
prestaciones de especialistas en los
cuales en el país no existen tanto
perdón tenemos una lista de espera
bastante alta tercero quizás para para
corroborar lo que decías en general en
chile el 80% la ciudadanía está suscrito
al fondo nacional de salud y solamente
el 20 por ciento del capital al servicio
privado lo que sí ha sucedido que fue
una reforma en los últimos de los
últimos 12 años reporta exactamente es
que individuos que tienen
financiamiento público o del estado
fonasa que les llevamos en chile si
pueden tener prestaciones de servicios
en el servicio obligado sin embargo se
pagan al valor del servicio privado por
lo tanto la apuesta desde el gobierno a
través del estado es que el servicio
público sea capaz de suplir toda la
demanda y toda la necesidad que hasta
hoy ha sido suplida pero en parte por
los sectores de servicio salud privados
y para quiere decir
el mejor ejemplo que tenemos de esto por
la responder respuesta a la pandemia es
la gran capacidad de crecimiento del
servicio salud se vio principalmente en
camillas en servicio de atención privado
y no necesariamente el servicio sano
público
claro y eso hace parte de esa idea del
sistema de bienestar que quiere
implementar el presidente boris tomar su
opinión sobre este tema de salud
aumentar la solidaridad en el
financiamiento también de algunos
procedimientos puntuales es otro de los
puntos que ha destacado el presidente
boris en cuanto a la salud en el país
como lo vio usted
si a mí me parece que el presidente
boris coloca el eje en el eje importante
en que la salud la educación y también
la protección social son parte de la
actividad del estado
como viene en la mayoría de los países
nosotros tenemos un sector aunque y un
sector todavía importante que se
autofinancia tanto la salud como también
las prestaciones sociales por lo tanto
yo creo que apunta aún a solucionar un
tema de fondo a mí también me llamó la
atención en la reforma de salud un plan
de salud mental hoy día la salud mental
en nuestro país es una prioridad y me
parece que ese ese plan a desarrollar
sobre todo a nivel local me parece muy
interesante es lo que está planteando
ahí ahora tanto en el sistema de salud
como en la reforma de pensiones
aquí hay una cuestión crucial que es una
reforma tributaria porque hoy día
nuestra nuestra capacidad de recaudación
del estado es insuficiente para
transformar esos sistemas por lo tanto
esta reforma
y el gran punto del fondo de la
discusión política en chile por esta
reforma tributaria que permita la
financiación de este tipo de prestación
si tomas usted se adelantó un poco a mi
siguiente pregunta que era precisamente
esa reforma tributaria el curso que esto
pueda tener queda muy bien planteado
suena en el discurso con mucha ilusión
pero qué tan factible es que se logre
teniendo una presencia de los
empresarios que muchos no están de
acuerdo con esta reforma tributaria por
supuesto
tomás
sí ahí está ahí está el punto político
yo diría que que va a ser el eje de la
disputa
fundamentalmente porque las reformas
tributarias hasta el momento han sido
bastante tímidas en el caso de chile no
han sido grandes y como todas las
reformas tributarias los gobiernos
plantean que van a recaudar un
porcentaje del pib pero al final de ese
porcentaje que no resulta ser real
evidentemente cuando entramos a
modificar la estructura tributaria de
las grandes empresas de las pequeñas de
los medianas y de los ciudadanos
sin duda es un tema de alta sensibilidad
no solamente para el mundo empresarial
sino que también para la ciudad porque
además estamos en un contexto muy
complejo en chile donde estamos viviendo
ya después de casi una década estamos
conociendo la inflación ya tenemos una
inflación de un 9% casi 10 a anualizada
y eso es una cosa que no estábamos
acostumbrados por lo tanto ese tema
en el desarrollo de
las posibilidades que tengan de
ejecutarse está todo grande reforma
jose mundial su opinión sobre el tema
tributario factible es una gran apuesta
y es bastante osado tratar de hacer
estos cambios más cuando hubo ese
estallido social hay todavía cierto
descontento no solamente en chile sino
en buena parte de los países de américa
latina- ahora digamos que en chile hay
expectativa por lo que pueda venir pero
el descontento y el rechazo todavía se
mantiene entre muchos sectores
sin duda que esta va a ser la prueba
política más importante en la gestión
del gobierno presidente boris en qué
sentido
la gran realidad que no podemos negar
intentar trabajar con el sol con un dedo
es que el actual gobierno no cuenta con
mayoría parlamentaria ni en la cámara
diputados ni en el senado por lo tanto
todas estas reformas cualquiera reforma
que se proponga tiene que ser capaz de
convocar de sentarse a negociar negociar
con las distintas oposiciones que ya son
mucho más inorgánicas son mucho más
desagregada que en el chile veinte años
atrás y tiene que ser capaz de primero
que todo convocarnos a la mesa que estén
dispuestos a negociar segundo llegar con
propuestas que logren convencer e
invitar a las a estas oposiciones y
tercero llegar a acuerdos que
efectivamente cumplan con con atraer o
ganar votos desde la oposición pero
también dar cuenta y dar solución a la
demanda la ciudadanía es algo que nos
vamos que no se va a solucionar en el
corto plazo algo que probablemente no se
cierre este año calendario tampoco y sin
duda que va a ser la gran
prueba de fuego considero yo en términos
políticos respecto a la gestión del
actual gobierno sí bueno avanzó un poco
más rápido porque tengo poco tiempo para
el programa hay muchos puntos para
analizar para cerrar este primer bloque
de reducción laboral de la jornada
laboral a 40 horas y también una
propuesta para una ley al derecho a la
eutanasia también lo voy a poner sobre
la mesa del debate tomás su opinión
sobre estos dos temas
yo creo que las 40 horas han sido un
proyecto que ha impulsado la coalición
de gobierno ya hace años
y me parece que es una demanda adecuada
en el sistema lo que lo que yo no veo no
no lo veo complejo en su implementación
porque él también el presidente de la
república ha planteado aquí eso hacer
no inmediatos sino que va a tener un
periodo de transición y va a ir
lentamente adecuándose pero me parece
que va bien va bien encaminado en ese
sentido
naturalmente y respecto a la impotencia
bueno ahí va a tener discusión porque es
un tema valórico
la sociedad chilena tiene una parte un
mundo conservador muy fuerte por lo
tanto ahí va a tener una oposición y
como bien decía josé miguel es a muchas
veces se plantean en en el congreso pero
me parece que es una discusión propia
del siglo que vivimos es clara y muy
propia de las libertades ya comenzaba a
tener
discusiones en diferentes países de
américa latina veíamos el caso de
colombia hace un par de semanas es una
discusión que está sobre la mesa en
varios países
jose miguel pasó al segundo punto si
tiene algo para añadir en cuanto a lo de
las 40 horas semanales bienvenido pero
avanzó hacia el tema de mejor democracia
en donde habla de la transparencia la
necesidad de mejorar los procesos en un
proyecto de ley que fortalece la
prevención de conflictos de intereses
todo este tipo de procedimientos para
las adjudicaciones de los de las obras
públicas y el ministerio de los pueblos
indígenas el tema democracia y si quiero
añadir algo el punto anterior también
bienvenido
concuerdo cuanto más que la discusión de
las 40 horas va a ser medianamente
administrativa no no creo que haya una
gran oposición pero también considero
que poner en el primer mensaje en la
propuesta de una discusión de la aut en
asia es muy probablemente una estrategia
mucho más política en contra la
oposición y para poder tener ciertas
monedas ciertas monedas de cambio es la
negociación parlamentaria con la
oposición es decir el gobierno hoy día
ajuste ese se abrió un espacio a favor
en el cual dice bueno perfecto sé que
ustedes me colaboran en continuar por
ejemplo con la agenda con la discusión
tributaria yo perfectamente podría echar
piedras en la discusión del tema la
obtenida si lo contratamos para adelante
por lo tanto creo que una jugada
bastante hábil y muy pensada en mediano
y largo plazo los segundos el respecto
del tema de mayor mayor de más y mejor
democracia sin durante el tema la
transparencia ha sido uno de la gran
piedra en el zapato de la democracia de
nuestra democracia reciente no de los de
los últimos 30 años lamentablemente la
última década o los últimos 15 en nuevo
entrado de grandes casos de que en chile
como sociedad y como sistema político
hemos decidido llamarlos el
financiamiento irregular de la política
pero no así ilegal porque porque para
eso se requiere la legislación que los
declara en forma ilegal asimismo han
habido señales mixtas seis señales
medidas medias difícil de entender en el
cuales por ejemplo se ha cambiado la
legislación y se ha declarado que los
delitos tributarios son los posibles
delitos tributarios
pierden su no pueden ser juzgada más
allá de cuatro años que precisamente el
periodo entre una elección y otra por lo
tanto avanzar en mayor transparencia
creo que son señal sumamente importante
potente y necesaria clara la calidad
democracia del país
tomás el ministerio de los pueblos
indígenas aquí un poco un guiño a la
situación de la araucanía también esa
difícil situación que se está viviendo
allí que ha sido también un debate de
varias décadas en chile la restitución
de tierras que es una demanda de estos
pueblos indígenas hay en el sur del país
punto álgido en la coyuntura política
chilena
si es un punto álgido porque tienen
muchas miradas y efectivamente en los
pueblos originarios y días han centrando
el debate en el país me parece que el
anuncio de donde bueno cada presidente
siempre anuncia más ministerio en esto
hemos reiterado en nuestro país cada
presidente anuncia ministerio aquí
tenemos uno este presidente anunció de
óptica pero más allá de eso me parece
que la política orientada hacia los
pueblos originarios tiene un enfoque
importante porque le da una
institucionalidad primer lugar y es más
integral no es nuestra cuestión
meramente discursiva sino que tiene
integralidad sobre todo en materia de la
araucanía donde el presidente ha
reiterado a través de su discurso la
idea de establecer más allá de las
cuestiones policiales que tienen que ver
con la violencia un diálogo donde él
dice me juego mi capital político por
hacer pues yo creo que
es una señal adecuada de abordar esta
problemática acerca de los pueblos
originarios en nuestro debate de una
manera adecuada
una manera adecuada a su
punto de vista 'josé miguel' sobre este
punto de los pueblos originarios y esta
creación de este ministerio de los
pueblos indígenas
creo que responde a parte importante de
las demandas de los pueblos originarios
tenemos más allá de un reconocimiento
constitucional que está escrito en la
nueva propuesta constitución que va a
ser votada ahora en septiembre para
también incorporarlos con mucho más
deberes y beneficios también desde el
punto de vista institucional es bastante
efectivo si nos vamos la discusión de
fondo sin embargo adquiera la gran la
gran expectativa respecto al discurso
del día de hoy que era dar medidas
particulares contra la inflación y
también muy particulares tal como
estamos viendo las imágenes respecto al
conflicto armado de la zona loca ni a
creo sin embargo que la creación del
ministerio no apunta a resolver este
problema en particular
bueno la opinión de nuestro invitado
tercer punto de esos ejes temáticos del
presidente de boris en su discurso la
justicia esto también va un poco ligado
con este tema la araucanía mejorar la
seguridad en el país precisamente haya
tenido que extender el estado de
excepción para poder garantizar la
seguridad hay despliegue de los
militares en esta en esta región y
también garantizar la seguridad
ciudadana que se ha visto seriamente
afectada no solamente en santiago en el
área metropolitana sino en otras grandes
ciudades del norte y del sur del país el
tema de seguridad qué tan grave es que
tan complejo es para la ciudadanía y
esta creación de un ministerio de
seguridad y protección civil puede
llevar y conducir a mejorar los índices
de inseguridad como lo voy tomás
a ver la seguridad
en el orden en general del término de
nivel con delincuencia con acciones
violentas con narcotráfico etcétera es
de las primeras preocupaciones que las
encuestas de opinión pública nos
reflejan por lo tanto es un tema central
y yo creo que hace un tema que ha
afectado en la popularidad y el respaldo
del gobierno en estos en estos pocos
tiempos
básicamente porque no había tenido ahí
el gobierno una agenda política clara
para abordar esta materia lo que hace
ahora el presidente es por lo menos
colocar en una agenda que tiene que ver
es básicamente con reforzamiento de
ciertas actividades de la policía una
inversión en recursos
pero al mismo tiempo
establecer caminos
paralelos para combatir el tráfico a
través de fortalecer los servicios de
inteligencia que son muy débiles chiles
y por lo tanto yo creo que por lo menos
el presidente yo creo que esto no apunta
básicamente a una me parece a mí que no
no va a tener un efecto como el que se
espera sin embargo lo que valoro es que
por lo menos ahora se aprecia una agenda
pero yo creo que el tema de seguridad va
a ser muy complejo y no podemos vivir
con estado de excepción constitucional
porque eso internamente y externamente
es muy malo para la ciudadanía y para el
país claro otro punto importante de este
eje de justicia a jose miguel es mejorar
carabineros de chile que estuvieron en
el punto en el ojo del huracán durante
las protestas del estallido social
también fueron muy criticados
precisamente por el actual presidente
boris va a invertir 1.800 millones de
pesos chilenos para mejorar las
capacidades de la policía en cuanto a
investigación de los casos
también algo que llamó mucho la atención
a raíz de los hechos recientes en eeuu
una propuesta de ley que permita la
prohibición de porte total de armas en
el territorio chileno punto
destacado que ha llamado mucho la
atención por lo menos fuera de las
fronteras de chile
sí yo creo que efectivamente estos
anuncios de los que apuntan y van a
buscar das una solución
tanto al nivel de delitos y también la
percepción
de inseguridad que existe la ciudadanía
y también cumple con un segundo un
segundo rol o la segunda función que es
muy importante que debe dar una señal de
respaldo y de respeto a la institución
de carabineros porque lo pongo sobre la
mesa porque cuando el actual gobierno en
la oposición se criticó mucho a mí desde
mi punto de vista con razón el actuar en
muchos casos de carabineros en donde
violan los derechos humanos y hoy día
estando en el gobierno también se
percibe que el rol es distinto y por lo
tanto es necesario mejorar y potenciar
la institucionalidad y respeto
respetando los y también se incorpora
una frase que fue muy importante la
reforma de carabineros es con los
carabineros por lo tanto también hace un
llamado a involucrarlos a invitarlos a
que se sientan parte de esto y para que
en el corto y mediano plazo nos volvamos
a ver y presenciar en lamentable que la
zona de derecho humano por la policía
del estado
y fue muy claro en decir es una reforma
es una actualización no es una
eliminación y reducirles sus capacidades
eso fue claro el presidente ya voy
llegando a la parte final del programa
por lo menos al último bloque y vamos
entonces con el cuarto punto el
crecimiento y la inclusión aquí hubo
varios puntos para destacar está la
reforma tributaria que ya lo tocamos un
poco más temprano pero
busca el presidente mejorar la
productividad laboral el crecimiento del
país propone entonces
y hacer crecer el país a un ritmo de 15
por ciento al año para poder sacar
adelante la economía después del receso
que hubo a nivel económico por la
pandemia covile 19 un plan nacional de
desarrollo pero ferroviario que también
es un plan de infraestructura muy
ambicioso para unir con una vía férrea
por lo menos santiago y el puerto de
valparaíso y también un plan bastante
ambicioso en minería y en una empresa
nacional de litio hay resumo más o menos
el punto número 4 impresiones sobre este
punto comienzo con tomás
y ahora yo te diría que las expectativas
son muestra del 1.5 ha sido básicamente
el crecimiento que hemos tenido en el
último tiempo sin embargo me parece
adecuado dado la magnitud de los cambios
que está proponiendo en esta materia
como cómo se centra y yo diría aquí que
el gran los grandes puntos son los que
tú has reseñado en esta en esta materia
y que efectivamente
agregan diría yo alguna expectativa
respecto a hacia dónde se va a
desarrollar economía en el país ahora
llama la atención si la que no haya
alguna medida concreta que ve al sector
privado que muchas veces se siente
excluidos está de estas cuestiones no
esté ahí considerado porque el gobierno
anunció un plan también de zonas
extremas por ejemplo a proteger a
inversiones en las zonas extremas que
resulta un anhelo para las zonas
extremas del país tanto en el norte como
en el sur
y lo que tú dices del litio bueno ahí
hay una licitación en camino y él
propone de crear una empresa nacional de
litio una cuestión distinta entonces me
parece que ahí faltó un espacio para el
sector privado para ver cómo se también
colabora en el crecimiento del país que
siendo algunas son una pieza en fortune
importantísima para la economía chilena
'josé miguel' su punto sus impresiones
sobre este cuarto punto
creo que el ofrecer y convocar a las
construcciones de obras en particular
las obras ferroviarias resucitar la
infraestructura y como el ferrocarril
logró unir en términos tanto formales
como simbólicos también el país de norte
a sur década atrás es sin duda un gesto
que tiene un componente simbólico de
lograr convocar unir de unir unirnos
como personas como ciudadanos pero
también una medida económica bastante
eficiente y eficaz porque porque este
tipo de obra genera mucho mano de obra
mucho empleo y también trae beneficios
directos y materiales a la ciudadanía
ven llegar el tren a sus a sus hogares
perturbar sus comunidades en
infraestructura etcétera etcétera
segundo también apunta a modificar un
poco en la matriz de desarrollo
tercero que también es ese es un mensaje
que hay que leer entre líneas es en
general el poder político el poder de
bloqueo de los sectores o de las
agrupaciones de camioneros en chile ha
sido históricamente ha sido bastante
fuerte en la última semana también hubo
una movilización poniendo en jaque la
edición política y policial desde el
gobierno por lo tanto la construcción
del anuncio la construcción de los
ferrocarriles tienen muy distinta perdón
tiene múltiples miradas interpretaciones
en términos políticos en términos
laborales en términos económicos
haciendo eco a tu a tu comentario
respecto a incorporar el sector privado
no efectivamente el desarrollo del cobre
en chile es en dos tercios
desarrollado y elaborado por privados
sin embargo históricamente ha sido una
empresa pública codelco la que ha tenido
un desarrollo un poco más lento o
siempre por detrás del desarrollo
privado por lo tanto la industria
privada es capaz de producir de mejor
manera de forma más económica mejorando
las leyes la calidad del cobre y en
términos relativos en términos
comparados la empresa pública ha quedado
con él con particular ha quedado un poco
rezagada en el proceso por eso entiendo
yo que el anuncio se han particular a
codelco y no a la industria el core en
general porque no hasta ahora ha sido
codelco quien ha estado levemente detrás
de la desarrollo tecnológico de los
privados y el presidente boris anuncio a
más de 90 millones de dólares en
exploraciones y 86 millones de dólares
para la innovación y tecnología
precisamente en codelco pero esto esto
se cruza un poco con ese quinto punto
este tema de la minería sabemos lo
importante que es la minería y la
extracción de cobre para la economía
chilena y para las regiones del norte
del país pero esto va un poco en corte
con ese quinto punto que es medio
ambiente y es precisamente generar otros
recursos y otras formas de financiación
que no vayan o que vayan mejor en favor
de preservar el medio ambiente allí y
hay varios puntos en este quinto y
último punto sobre el medio ambiente la
aprobación que lo veíamos en las últimas
horas del ingreso de chile el acuerdo de
escazú también un marco una ley de marco
climático que también ya fue presentada
por el gobierno y también hizo énfasis
en las regiones que tienen problemas con
la sequía que lleva el país padeciendo
desde hace varios meses y las casas de
agua el tema del agua en chile es
completamente algo extraordinario que no
sea un bien público sino que sea casi
que un bien privado porque tienen que
pagar
enormes cantidades de dinero medio
ambiente para finalizar tomas
yo creo que es uno de los ejes
programáticos del gobierno y desde ese
punto de vista él plantea yo diría
un eje bastante claro hacia dónde es
emergen no solamente con la aprobación
del tratado es casus de los logros en
estos pocos días o meses de gobierno
sino que también en adelante como tú
dices el medio ambiente un tema judía
crítico y central que va a ser un eje
fundamental del gobierno y como tal los
proyectos que el presidente anuncia en
esta materia me parece que van en la
línea en la línea adecuada creo que
quien no solamente tiene que ver con lo
interno sino que también propone una
alianza más allá e
internacional para proteger
los mares y los recursos me parece que
el medio ambiente sigue siendo un tema
en desarrollo y creo que hay ahí una
veta que el gobierno lentamente puede ir
explorando con mayor rapidez
evidentemente los temas del agua
vivimos 10 años estamos en diez años de
sequía por lo tanto han sido el duro
momento
hay la primera y una una una
preocupación
me da un poco más de un minuto o jose
miguel para cerrar con este tema sus
opiniones
con nuestros dos hitos en la clave
política interna no el acuerdo de escazú
lo podríamos interpretar de la misma
forma de cómo cuando por ejemplo
presidente by the envuelve el acuerdo de
parís está dando cuenta de que las
relaciones internacionales tuvieron
bastante abandonadas o no fue una
prioridad del gobierno anterior por lo
tanto yo lo leo en esa clave y lo
segundo muy en la clave de la política
interna al declarar que el agua no puede
ser no puede ser un bien privado sino
que tiene que ser un buen un bien
público está dando pie la orientación
política del gobierno de aquí en
adelante no vamos a mejorar un sistema
de protección social vamos a quizás a
nacionalizar o defender bienes públicos
por lo tanto las formas en las cosas la
visión de ciudadano la visión de
democracia que tenemos es muy distinta a
nuestros antecesores pues a jose miguel
cabeza hacia tomás duval les agradezco
por haber hecho este análisis de este
primer discurso esta rendición de
cuentas del presidente chileno gabriel
boric que hemos transmitido aquí en
france 24 gracias por explicar para la
audiencia fuera de las fronteras
chilenas para entender cómo está
entonces el panorama político de ese
país y cómo se proyecta para este
gobierno del presidente boris que se
extiende hasta el 2026 muchas gracias
por haber estado con nosotros y ustedes
muchas gracias también por sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]